[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800
83567 47 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Jean Ross
Hello friends how about an amazing fact
in the summer of 1823 near the fork of
the Grand River in present day South
Dakota Hugh glass a fur trapper and
Frontiersman
encountered a grizzly bear and her two
Cubs before he could fire his rifle the
bear charged clawing and biting him
severely his fellow Trappers managed to
kill the bear but glass was left badly
molded and
unconscious believing that he would soon
die from his injuries the Expedition
leader Andrew Henry asked John
Fitzgerald and a young Jim Bridger who
would later become a legendary Mountain
Man himself to stay behind with glass
until he died after a few days of
waiting and fearing attacks by hostile
Indians Fitzgerald and Bridger convinced
of glass's imminent death took his rifle
knife and other equipment and returned
to the Expedition group reporting that
glass had died but Against All Odds
glass survived he regained Consciousness
and he found himself alone devoid of his
supplies suffering from a broken leg
exposed ribs from where the bear had
torn away his flesh and serious injuries
to his head and arms nevertheless he was
determined to live and reach safety he
used the stick to stabilize his broken
leg and surviving on wild berries and
leftover meat from Wolf kills he crawled
more than 200 miles to Fort kiaa a
journey that took him over 6 weeks
glass's incredible survival Journey
became legendary symbolizing the harsh
realities of the American frontier and
the Extreme Measures that you glass took
to cling to life you know friends this
story reminds me of the story of Job in
the Bible who also facing immense
suffering yet maintained an unwavering
faith in God during his ordeal he
declared though he slay me yet will I
trust him that is Job 13:15 through
perseverance and faith in God we too can
endure trials and tribulations knowing
that God will ultimately Deliver Us from
all evil and pain and will will one day
make all things new this is the hope
that has sustained Christians throughout
history enabling them to face
persecution sorrow and even death you
know Jesus gave these words of promise
to all believers John chapter 14 ver1
Jesus said let not your hearts be
troubled if you believe in God believe
also in Me In My Father's House Jesus
said there are many mansions if it were
not so I would have told you I go to
prepare a place for you he said and if I
go and prepare a place for you I will
come again and receive you unto myself
that where I am there you may be also
that is the promise Jesus said he will
come again this world is not our home
but we're looking forward to a Heavenly
Home a New Jerusalem where there is
peace and joy no more pain no more
sorrow God will make all things new and
friends do you have that hope in your
heart do you believe believe that heaven
is for real and that Jesus is coming
back and that you can have a place in
that Heavenly Kingdom I hope so we do
have a free offer Pastor eron that talks
about this wonderful hope that
Christians have yes we do and it is a
booklet entitled Heaven is it for real
uh written by actually my grandfather
Joe Cruz and if you would like to get
your hands on this for a deeper study
into the topic you can call as you see
on the screen if you're watching 1 1800
47 and you can get that offer right then
and there just call and ask for it ask
for it by name you can also get that by
dialing pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible aners live and then ask for the
book by name Heaven is it for real and
you will be blessed by reading this book
read it share it with your family
members give it to a friend we do have
hope as Christians this world is not our
final home Pastor Doug is out this
evening but this is live interactive
Bible Study Bible answers live so if you
have a Bible related question we'd love
to hear from you this evening the number
to call here to the studio is 800
46372 N7 that is 8800 God says 800 463
7297 we want to greet all of our friends
who are listening on the various uh
radio stations on satellite radio also
on AFV watching on the internet and
joining me here in the studio is Pastor
Aon Cruz and he's going to be working
the phones we appreciate him taking the
time to he's got a wealth of information
about the Bible as well so he'll be
answering these Bible questions with me
as we take the various questions but
Pastor Cruz before we go to the phone
lines why don't we start with prayer
absolutely let's bow our heads dear
heavenly father Lord we thank you so
much for this opportunity to study your
word and to field some of these
questions that are on so many people's
minds and hearts Hearts so Lord we ask
for your spirit to be here as we uh
share Faithfully uh from your word what
uh the scriptures say about these
various things and give those who are
inquisitive Minds trying to figure out
for themselves a special blessing as
they listen for themselves but then
ultimately turn back to the Bible and
find the truth of your word for
themselves we pray in Jesus name amen
amen all right well we've got a number
of folks who are waiting with their
Bible question who do we have first all
right our first question is a caller
from the great state that we're in
California and his name is Lou uh
calling in with a question about Daniel
11 so Lou hey welcome to the show what's
your question for us today yeah thank
you uh my question was from uh about the
King of the North and the King of the
South going to war in the very last days
and I'm wondering if you can elaborate
on that a little bit expand a little and
tell us who you think they might be and
so forth and so on okay great all right
we appreciate the question of course you
read about uh the King of the North and
the King of the South in Daniel chapter
11 it's the longest chapter that you'll
find in the Book of Daniel it is also
the most detailed prophecy talking about
the rise and fall of different kingdoms
so the first reference that we have to
the King of the North and the King of
the South relates to different kingdoms
over time of course you have Babylon
that fell to Meo Persia and Meo Persia
fell to Greece and then the Grecian
kingdom was divided up into four
different parts and there were two
prominent generals that sort of took
charge the one in the North and the one
in the South the one in the South was
bamy and he kind of established the bamy
dynasty or tmy Dynasty depending how you
pronounce it the sald dynasty was in the
north and uh the two Powers the King of
the North and the King of the South uh
through much of the chapter describes
their activities they were going back
and forth to war now the reason those
two are mentioned is because the people
of God Jerusalem was right in the middle
between the King of the North and the
King of the South and so every time they
would embark on a military campaign it
would very often affect the people of
God and Israel would change hands from
the power of the Grecian Empire back to
the Egyptians and we go back and forth
but when you get to Revelation chapter
40 the King of the North and the King of
the South even a little before that
actually the King of the North Begins to
take on more of a role of first Pagan
Rome and then it follows with papal Rome
and much of the chapter nearing the end
deals with the King of the North
representing Pap the papal power and the
King of the South has been identified in
two ways the one would be uh the King of
the South would represent those
religions that are opposed to God sort
of paganism and even atheism that we see
coming up during the French Revolution
uh some new interpretations especially
as you relate to chapter 40 I feel that
perhaps the King of the South might be a
coalition of some atheist IC kingdoms or
powers that are backing um Islamic
nations of course Egypt today is Islamic
so some are suggesting maybe you have on
the one side you have the Western Powers
supporting the papal power and you have
China maybe even North Korea and Russia
and some of these others supporting the
Islamic Nations and maybe there's a big
Showdown now of course chapter 40
onwards is still in the future so some
of the specifics of this we don't quite
yet know but that's the leading
interpretation the leading idea as to
who the king of the North and the King
of the South is it is a very detailed
study and if you'd like to learn more
about that I'd encourage you to take a
look at some of the resources and
amazing facts but uh it is fascinating
and we're living right around that time
period after verse 40 that you read
about in Daniel chapter 11 all right
thank you Lou who do we have next all
right our next caller his name is
Patrick calling in from Canada seems
like Patrick you have a question about
the Apocrypha welcome to the show good
evening um yes my question is about the
54 books of the Apocrypha and um it's
relationship to the Bible I'm not sure
if it has a relationship or uh I just
want to find out if it's inspired or or
not okay very good the apocryphal books
um you'll sometimes find it in uh the
Catholic Bible you don't often find it
in Protestant Bibles uh the reason for
that is that when the reformers were
working on putting together what we call
the cannon of scripture or the Bible as
we have it now they recognized that the
apocryphal books didn't really line up
with the other inspired books of the
Bible for several reasons uh for one the
authorship of some of the apocryphal
books is somewhat questionable sometimes
somebody would write a book and then
they would ascribe a name of a famous
Bible character like Enoch or something
like that but it wasn't really the one
who wrote the book kind of give it
Credence also some of the doctrine of of
some of the Apocrypha books actually
contradict Old Testament passages as
well as the New Testament books written
by Paul and the apostles uh there is
some interesting history that you can
read about in the apocryphal especially
in the books of mccabes but they more
historical and they describe that time
period from uh sort of the inter
Testament time periods that bring you
from the last book written Malachi up
until Matthew what was happening in
Israel during that time so the reason
they're not part of the Bible is because
the Protestant recognize that they
they're not inspired they're not on the
same level as the rest of scripture and
the Au who the author is is somewhat
questionable on some of the books so
that's why you don't find it in the
Protestant Bible yeah great answer all
right next question our next caller is
calling in from Ohio and we have Glenn
here with us on the line hi Glenn what
is your question for us this evening yes
good evening thank you gentlemen for
taking my call you know when a person is
converted Ed they are
forgiven and it is with the application
of 1 John 1:9 the daily bath they can be
forgiven until the end or they can jump
off the wagon anytime and jump back on
the love of God covers them during that
period of
gestation but if they do endure Until
the End Matthew 24:13 tells us They will
receive the gift of
Salvation and he receive it eternally
secure so therefore for the answer to
the question can a saved man choose to
be lost is wondrously no all right well
yeah let me share a little bit about
that because it sounds like yeah you you
made an interesting statement can a Sav
man choose to be lost well I think we
have freedom of choice even a converted
person doesn't lose their freedom of
choice that's why the Bible as you
mentioned Jesus said he that endures to
the end shall be saved but for someone
that is trusting in Jesus that is
surrendering to him
uh Jesus promises that they are secure
no one can take them out of his hand but
they can still choose if they will so if
we're trusting in Jesus we can have
confidence that he forgives US 1 John 1
ver9 if confess our sins he faithful and
just to forgive us to cleanse us from
all unrighteousness and as long as we
are abiding in him as Jesus said abide
in me and I in you as the branch cannot
be fruit of itself except that abide in
the vine neither can you except you
abide in me and Jesus says if you do not
abide they will be removed the bran
should be removed from the vine so yes
there is an abiding that's needed and we
choose to abide it's something that we
do uh we still have freedom right up
until you know Jesus comes we can choose
so nobody loses that freedom to choose
we choose to be saved and we choose to
remain in a saving relationship with
Jesus and as long as we are doing that
we have no fear that we'll be lost
because we are trusting in Him and his
blood cleanses us from all sin you know
we do have a book called can a save man
choose to be lost I think that deals
with this question exactly and we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks what's the number it's uh 1800 835
6747 to get that uh I think that's the
title of the book can can a save man
choose be lost yeah and it explains that
and gives a whole lot of scripture so
yes Glenn call and ask for that you can
also do pound 250 on your smartphone
just say Bible answers live and then ask
for the book can a man say a saved man
choose to be lost and will give you a
digital download you'll be able to read
it right away yeah all right who do we
have next all right our next caller is
Shannon calling in from Georgia and
looks like you have a question about the
book of Hebrews hi Shannon welcome hi
yes I'm calling I've been searching to
find out who wrote the book of Hebrews
and some of their writing sounds like
Paul that I can't find anywhere where it
actually says he wrote the book of
Hebrews or who wrote the the book of
Hebrews okay good question you're right
the book of Hebrews does not give its
authorship it almost appears as though
the author um was recognized by the
reader as being somebody having
Authority also when you read Hebrews you
understand that whoever wrote the book
was very much aware of the Jewish system
the Old Testament the sacrifices the
priesthood the sanctuary and everything
associated with that and of course he
brings the connection between the
sacrifice repres Jesus the priesthood
representing Jesus he goes into great
detail talks about the Heavenly
Sanctuary with Jesus ministers as the
high priest and even though it's not
clearly stated uh many Bible scholars
believe that actually Paul is the one
that wrote Hebrews even though the
language might be a little different in
some way say it sounds a little
different from Romans but remember the
audience was different so Romans was
primarily to a gentile audience but
Hebrews was written to a Jewish audience
uh but just the depth of knowledge and
understanding of uh the Jewish system as
well as the fact that the author was
considered to be an authority to be an
apostle many believe that that was Paul
who wrote the book of Hebrews when we
get to heaven we'll know for sure we'll
know for sure we'll know for sure all
right our next caller is Gary calling in
from
Illinois hello uh we've got Gary here
welcome to the program thank you in
Revelation 16 the Euphrates River dries
up demons are released enticing the
kings of the world to meet at Armageddon
if a nuclear war should happen would the
hail the size of a talent be the outcome
of that war which is mentioned at the
end of chapter 16 okay well good
question yes uh you read about this in
Revelation chapter 16 verse1 12 where it
talks about the drying up of the river
Euphrates now this is part of what we
call the seven last plagues it's
actually the sixth plague and you start
reading there in verse 12 through to
verse 16 so there are a series of
plagues that come upon the Earth just
before Jesus comes and when it talks
about hail falling upon the Earth and a
great earthquake which is the seventh
plague that brings you right up to the
second coming of Christ so these plagues
take place before Jesus comes uh the
first plague if you read about it it's a
terrible sore that develops upon people
and then it talks about the sea turning
to blood then the rivers turning to
blood and then the sun scorches men with
intense heat and so on and so forth so
these are literal plagues that'll come
upon the Earth it hasn't happened yet it
happens after probation closes
so when Michael stands up in Daniel
chapter 12 Jesus says he that is Holy
let him be holy still he is that filthy
let him be filthy still that's
revelation 22 probation
closes the righteous are sealed the
Wicked at the mark of the beast and then
the seven last plagues fall and the
drawing up of the river Euphrates is an
interesting play because it has a
symbolic application it's not only
referring to the literal river Euphrates
which very well could dry up but if you
go back in Bible History you have the
city of Babylon this is during the time
of the Jewish captivity the Jews are
captive in Babylon and in order for the
Jews to be set free to go back to
Jerusalem you have Cyrus who is the uh
the meor Persian uh leader or general
and in order for them to conquer Babylon
they dried up the river Euphrates which
ran diagonally through the ancient city
of Babylon they diverted the waters into
some Marsh areas and as the river
lowered they were able to march their
soldiers under the massive City walls
and in one night Babylon fell after the
fall of Babylon Cyrus allowed the Jews
to go back and start rebuilding the
temple in Jerusalem so symbolically when
you see the drying up of the river
Euphrates it represents that God's
people are soon to be delivered from
symbolic Babylon and taken to the New
Jerusalem now watering Bible prophecy
according to Revelation chapter 17
represents multitude and Nations and
kindreds and tongues and so this
counterfeit religious system in the last
days referred to as Babylon in
Revelation 17 just before Jesus comes
the support that people are giving to
this apostate religious system will be
withdrawn because the previous plague
talks about Darkness upon the seed of
the Beast so people suddenly realize hey
we've been deceived by this power and
they withdraw their support that
prepares the way for the second coming
of Christ so this is a great study it's
referring to something yet in the future
and this is part of the seven last
plagues that you read about in
Revelation 16 hopefully that helps thank
you Gary all right our next caller uh is
calling in from Canada up north uh
caller named Deborah Deborah welcome to
the show what is your question for us
this evening hello pastors how are you
good thank you great I have a question
about Mark 14 yes versus 51 and 52 I
have to tell you that when I read it I
got
emotional okay other people have told me
that it's you know C Mark making a cameo
appearance and I've looked up the word
nakedness and I've looked up the word
linen because of the two things that the
story tells us and uh nakedness is
mentioned 104 times in the Bible and
linen represents Purity and nakedness
could be it could mean other things
other than shameful uh in the Bible
depending on where it's used so could
you tell me who he was or who you think
he is and is there a signif significance
to this I don't believe it's just a in
the Bible and I I don't really because
of how emotional I got I believe there's
something to this story sure absolutely
let me share what we have here so yes
you find this in Mark chapter 14 this is
at the time of the arrest of Jesus um
when um the religious leaders came with
the Roman soldiers they met Jesus in The
Garden of Gethsemane you'll remember how
Peter pulled out his sword and chopped
off the high priest's servant's ear
Jesus healed uh the servant and then he
allowed himself to be arrested and as he
been taken away uh the disciples all
began to run away and apparently there
was a young man who heard about what was
happening the reason it says he he was
wearing a linen it's late at night he
probably just grabbed a blanket or
whatever he had he heard about this and
he came out to see what was going on and
as they arrest Jesus and took him to
Caiaphas the high priest for this trial
they wanted to grab as many of his
followers as well and it seems as though
the Romans grabbed a hold of this young
man and him filled with fear just took
of running in his birthday suit so to
speak so um people believe that the
reason it's even mentioned there is that
it could very well be Mark himself he
was a young man at the time Mark of
course wrote the book he wasn't
officially one of the Disciples of Jesus
but he was there at the time and uh he
received an eyewitness account that came
from the apostles when he wrote the Book
of Mark so yes we believe that was him
uh the point being here is that really
everybody deserted Jesus and they ran
for their lives and that was a prophecy
that Jesus had mentioned would take
place it says uh the shepherd shall be
smitten and the Sheep shall disperse
they will run away and that's what
happened to the Disciples of Christ at
that time uh later on you read about um
John and Peter that follow Jesus at a
distance and they went into a Caiaphas
as high PR high priest place at least
the compound and they were there but it
seems that this young man from all
accounts as far as we know was probably
Mark and he ran away along with the
other disciples yeah another point is
it's significant that it's only the
gospel of Mark that records this little
incident here so uh It's Not Unusual we
have the Gospel of John where even
though it's quite clear that John wrote
the Gospel of John John never actually
fully identifies himself as the author
right so Mark could have been you know
throwing this personal anecdote in there
as well uh without claiming you know
like hey this was me by way and I wrote
this gospel yeah he's sort of saying hey
I was there I can verify I'm an
eyewitness account this is what happened
to me but I was there when Jesus was
arrested that's right very good thank
you Deborah who do we have next all
right next we have Christopher calling
in from California hi there Christopher
Welcome to our show what's your question
for us this evening good evening um my
my question is when is a close of
probation for everybody okay good
question yes the Bible doesn't give us
the exact time when probation will close
there are certain things that prophecy
for tells needs to take place before
probation closes so we know for one that
probation hasn't closed yet for example
some of the signs that Jesus gave he
said this Gospel of the Kingdom must be
preached to all the world as a witness
unto all nations then the end will come
if you still preaching the gospel that
means probation is not closed you can
also read in Revelation chapter 18 there
is a description of a mighty Angel we
call him the fourth angel of Revelation
18 because in chapter 14 you have three
angels and now you have this fourth
angel it says the Earth is illuminated
with his glory and he cries mightily
with a strong voice Babylon is Fallen is
fallen and that's referring to a special
outpouring of the Holy Spirit and a
Great Awakening amongst God's people in
taking the last warning message to the
world uh as we saw at Pentecost when the
Holy Spirit came upon the apostles and
the gospel went forth with power we will
see a similar thing just before
probation closes that has not happened
yet so we know that is still to come we
also know that before probation closes
there is going to be the issue of the
mark of the beast in other words people
will be forced to make a decision are
they going to worship God according to
the Commandments or are they going to
set aside one of God's Commandments in
order to worship according to the beast
power that's described there in
Revelation chapter 13 that hasn't
happened yet so there's a couple of
things that still have to take place and
once these things have taken place and
the loud cry is given then at some point
Jesus says it's over now Daniel 12:1 it
says Michael stands Michael is the
prophetic name of Christ and there is a
time of trouble worse than the world has
ever seen that's when the seven last
plagues will be poured out but at that
time thy people shall be delivered
everyone found written in the book well
that's the second coming of Christ when
the righteous will be delivered so close
probation still in the future uh but of
course for us individually uh probation
can close any time right because when a
person dies their probation is closed
their decisions have been made that's
why the Bible says today is the day of
salvation do not Harden your heart so
every day we want to make that choice to
surrender to Jesus thank you Christopher
appreciate your call amen great great
answer and I love that emphasis on you
know the Bible says you know Jesus says
I'm coming soon I'm coming soon well
that was 2,000 years ago but we do
believe he's coming soon but everyone's
individual probation could close before
the corporate Final close of probation
all right Lee uh we have calling in from
Texas welcome Lee uh to the show what is
your question for us this evening yes my
question is why is Greek mythology
closely linked to the Bible Well when
you talk about Greek mythology closely
linked to the Bible um all Pagan
religions have certain kernels of truth
because in reality paganism is really
the religion inspired by the Devil
Himself and yes there is a controversy
between good and evil sometimes you'll
read about a fall even in certain Pagan
mythologies you even have a tree uh of
course it's Twisted the serpent or the
dragon also has significance in paganism
of course you read about the serpent in
Genesis so yes there are some
connections because you know paganism
was inspired by the devil Greek
mythology for the most part was built
upon these Pagan religious U teachings
that are false uh although you know a
lot of Greek myth mythology is just made
up as well it's not the truth the Bible
has the final word the Bible is the
truth but there are some interesting
things even in some remote tribal groups
they talk about a flood that you read
about in Genesis different ideas of it
but you get kernels of Truth scattered
well friends we're going to take a short
break and then we'll be back with more
of your Bible questions so stand by
we'll be back in just a
[Music]
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly Jerusalem the city of Peace has
been a place of honor ending Conflict
for centuries many now believe that
Jerusalem will soon take Center Stage
again but what does the Bible say the
fall and Rise of Jerusalem presents the
vital history you need to know about
Jerusalem and its role in Endtime Bible
prophecy this amazing facts edition of
the classic volume the great controversy
is the perfect sharing book get your
copy at AF bookstore.com
in 6 days God created the heavens and
the Earth
for thousands of years man has worshiped
God on the seventh day of the week now
each week millions of people worship on
the first day what happened why did God
create a day of rest does it really
matter what day we worship who is behind
this great shift discover the truth
behind God's law and how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
find out what the critics are raving
about top Scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the Book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this
95-minute masterpiece brings to life the
Book of Revelation like never before
Revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
700 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live this is a live interactive
International Bible study we want to
welcome you with your Bible questions if
you have a Bible question the phone line
is 800
747 my name is Jean Ross Pastor Doug is
out of town this evening but working the
phones and helping answer the Bible
questions is Pastor Arin Cruz who is one
of our pastors at the Granite Bay
Hilltop Church he's actually our young
adult Pastor glad you're able to help us
with Bible answers live yeah definitely
and I want to give a special greeting to
those who of course uh multiple avenues
that people can listen to the program
but also want to give a shout out to
those who are listening through 3abn as
well as the local radio station kpg C in
Norman Arkansas and ktie in Glendale
California so thanks so much for tuning
in now we're going to continue on with
our live questions and we have Terrence
calling in from North Carolina hello
Terrence welcome to the show what is
your question for us this
evening uh yes Pastor Ros Pastor C have
a question it's a simple one for you
tonight what were Jesus's last words was
it Luke
23:46 Psalms
221 John 1930 I think it's Luke 23:46
but uh it's conflicting okay yes I I
think you're right I mean there's a
number of of words that Jesus spoke and
not all of the gospels record all of his
words but if you take the different
statements of Christ from all of the
gospels you come up with with what the
total is uh Luke 23:46 says and when
Jesus had cried out with a loud voice he
said father into your hands I commit my
spirit having said this he breathed his
last so yes from the verse it appears
pretty clear that this was the last
thing that Jesus said incidentally it's
actually a quote a quote from Psalms
31:5 that Jesus was quoting a number of
the statements Jesus made from the cross
were actually uh quotes from the Old
Testament much from The Book of Psalms
part of that is that Jesus wanted to
direct those who were at the cross to go
back and to read these passages of
scripture to help validate that he was
indeed the Messiah the Fulfillment of
these various prophecies that you find
in the Old Testament so yes Luke chap
23:46 seems to be the the final words
that Jesus spoke when he said into thy
hands I commit my spirit and then he
died all right thank you Terrence who do
we have next all right we've got Esther
calling in from California with a
question about animal
hello Esther hello pastors hi um I
recently saw a documentary about beavers
and bees and how they keep the Sabbath I
was just wondering do animals praise God
okay well uh indirectly you know they
don't consciously say all right we're
going to worship God or or praise God
but when you look at the marvels of
creation and you look at what animals do
and you look at how they are made you
can see evidence of a Creator you can
see the handywork of God in the things
that he has made and so when you look at
a hummingbird and you see its beautiful
colors and you see how that it can drink
nectar from a flower while it's flying
and yet it has such endurance to fly
long distances that's all evidence that
there is a Creator God so in them just
doing what they were made to do they are
in essence praising God they're
revealing uh the glories of God not that
they purposely gather together in other
words when a bird sings He sings because
he's a bird but he's doing what God made
him to do and that in a sense is
praising God so yeah very good
observation yeah just uh a couple verses
along those lines we have Psalm 148 read
a couple verses here starting verse one
which says praise the Lord praise the
Lord from the heavens Praise Him in the
Heights praise him all the Angels praise
him all the hosts Praise Him sun and
moon praise him all you stars of light
uh Praise Him you heavens of heavens and
you Waters above the heavens let them
praise the name of the Lord so here we
have intangible things uh the the light
the the Sun the moon the stars who the
psalmist says praise him right and I
love what you said there Jean uh that
when when something is created by God an
animal a sun a moon and they're simply
doing what they were created to do in
that sense they're really giving praise
to God and so we um we have a we're made
in the image of God and we have a you
could say a higher degree of
Consciousness and when we intentionally
and purposely do what God created us to
do that is what matters the most for us
so and praising God in that sense amen
amen amen all right our next caller uh
who's a firsttime caller calling in from
Virginia Kalia thank you so much for
calling in and your question for us this
evening is yes um I I was calling to
find out does the devil worship on
Sabbath um because I I have a um
definition from the dictionary that says
the Sabbath is a meeting of
witches okay well you know whatever that
definition is from the dictionary is
wrong uh the Sabbath was created by God
it's a memorial of his creative work it
is a day of worship the righteous
worship on the day God set aside because
that's what he asked us to do God's
people throughout time have recognized
him as the Creator and have remembered
the Sabbath keep it holy the devil does
not worship God he hates God and he
hates anything that connects people to
God and the Sabbath would be one of
those things so the devil is doing his
very best to cause people to ignore or
forget this wonderful truth because you
know Jesus wants to spend time with us
Christ is the Creator God is has made us
and he's set aside a day where we can
actually enter into his presence in a
special way doesn't mean we can't
worship worship Him throughout the week
but this is a time that he has set aside
pour us to gather to worship and he
wants to bless us with his presence in a
special way on the seventh day and
always reminding us that he's the one
that made us we didn't make ourselves so
the devil hates the Sabbath uh he hates
worship and um yeah the Sabbath is a
good thing according to the Bible we do
have a study guide that talks about the
Sabbath and you might enjoy reading it
all you need to do is call and ask it's
called The Forgotten day in history
forgotten day in history and it's about
the Sabbath what the Bible says if you'd
like to receive it the number to call is
83567 47 or you can dial pound 250 on
your smartphone just say Bible answers
live and then say I want that study
guide called forgotten day in history or
while you're on the phone if you call
and you're speaking to one of the
operators you can sign up for free to
the amazing facts Bible school we have a
set of lessons we'll mail it to you
you'll be able to read through them look
them look up the Bible verses and you'll
be able to fill in the quiz send it back
to us and when you've done the whole
course you will get a certificate of
completion from amazing facts it's free
so take advantage of that you will be
blessed all right who do we have next
all right thank you uh our next caller
calling in from New York has a great
name uh Aaron which is my name Aaron
welcome to the program looks like you
have a question about Proverbs chapter 3
e i do Aaron thanks for calling and your
question tonight my question is what is
the meaning of that verse especially the
word acknowledge okay let me read it
Proverbs 3:6 it says in all of your ways
acknowledge Him and He Shall direct your
paths so the word they acknowledge means
to inquire and submit to his plans and
purposes in other words if you want God
to um direct your ways you need to be
willing to go in the way that he leads
you can't say all right Lord I'm going
to do my own thing and I hope this is
part of your plan no if you really want
God to bless then you need say Lord what
is your plan and that's what it means
when it says acknowledge Him in other
words seek his will say Lord what do you
want me to do uh we want to search the
scriptures make sure that what we are
wanting to do is in harmony with the
principles given in the Bible sometimes
we might need to seek some Godly counsel
from others but at the end of the day if
we know this is uh in harmony with the
will of God and we say Lord if it's your
will then through Providence open up the
doors close doors if you don't want me
to go a certain way that we can trust
that God is going to lead us
so to acknowledge Him is to seek his
will and then follow it and not doing
your own thing but saying Lord your will
be done so that's the key that's right
great question though very very
practical oh you know what I just
remembered a book Pastor Doug wrote a
book called determining the will of God
oh yeah and it's free we'll send it to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
8835 6747 that deals with this very
verse call and ask it's called
determining the will of God all right
thanks thanks aarin who do we have next
all right another caller in from New
York and it's Phil uh Phil you have an
interesting question for us this evening
what is it I hope I do thank you very
much I'll just take a second to say your
explanation about the Euphrates was
really superb because it ties together
religious and secular history it was
excellent amen well thank you my
question is do you believe that um woke
culture and Marxist glob IST ideology
are somehow connected to the One World
System of the Antichrist okay well good
question well in 1798 you had the French
Revolution which really was the
beginning of a Nation claiming atheism
and of course Marxism or Marx call Marx
and what he wrote which kind of came out
of that French Revolution influenced
communism atheism Evolution and many
other isms material iism and so on and
so forth sort of was the The Catalyst
for that uh what is interesting is that
there there are two extremes and of
course we can see this in our world
today on the one hand you would have
what we maybe consider the liberal or or
or the left side of things on the other
you'd have the conservatives and maybe
consider that the right side if you're
dealing with politics but what the Bible
does tell us and these two Powers these
two philosophies are seem to be uh you
know at odds with each other and they
are
but what the Bible tells us that at the
End of Time the Antichrist power is
going to be able to pull both groups
together he's going to unite them for a
particular cause which is going to lead
to the enforcing of the mark of the
beast now we don't have time to get into
the exact details we do have a study
guide that actually talks about the mark
of the beast but it is interesting how
that you're going to have on the one end
those who are very uh Pro you might say
environmental movements and social
Justice causes uniting with those who
are directly opposite on the religious
side of things who believe that because
of immorality because of what the
culture is doing the United States will
be doomed unless America gets back to
God and you have the Antichrist power
reaching sort of middle ground and
pulling both groups together and what is
interesting about this it's going to
revolve around a particular day now
without me saying too much get the study
and read it dealing with the Antichrist
power and the mark of the beast but it's
interesting that in the environmental
movement people are talking about the
Earth needing a day of rest once a week
and on the uh religious side of things
you've got the religious World saying we
need to get back to God we need to start
enforcing Sunday as a day of rest and
worship and it's interesting how these
two ideas will eventually merge together
being Guided by the Antichrist power in
the last days uh to enforce the the mark
of the beast so yes does what we see
happening in politics today and around
the world is that connected with the
Fulfillment of Prophecy absolutely these
are signs of the times and uh we're
living in some very exciting times yeah
and I'll I'll just add briefly there
there may be powers in the world that
seem to be totally opposite yet both are
against or somehow contrary to the Bible
and to to God and Satan will take
advantage of that it was after all the
Sadducees on the left side and the
Pharisees on the right side that came
together right along with the state that
crucified Jesus right so Satan finds his
his his friends everywhere right and
when it comes to attacking God's people
all the powers of the world ultimately
are going to team up together uh against
the righteous that's a good point you
know ultimately we need to trust in the
Bible we can't trust in what's happening
in politics we can't trust in different
organizations we got to trust the word
of God that's going to be our safety in
the last days Phil great question thanks
for calling uh you might want to get
that study guide called the Antichrist
there's actually two the mark of the
beast and the Antichrist for anyone
wanting to learn more about this very
important prophetic subject call 800 835
6747 ask for those two study guides
you'll be amazed when you read what the
Bible says who these powers are in the
last days okay who do we have next all
right next we have Alexander calling in
from New York and it looks like uh
you're a firsttime caller Alexander uh
we're so excited to have you here
welcome to the program what is your
question for us this evening uh good
evening and God bless you guys always
yeah
thanks my question is um because uh
we're studying um the great
controversy and I wanted to know if the
devil had a chance to visit all the
worlds with his lies or was it only
Earth that he got to deceive okay very
good well it appears as though he did at
some point and here's why in job you
read the book of Job it begins by
talking about a day when the sons of God
came to present themselves before God
now we know that these sons of God are
not uh human beings they are
representatives of other unfallen worlds
the Bible in Hebrews talks about God who
made the world uses the plural and they
are the representatives of these worlds
and Satan shows up at this meeting and
he comes representing Earth you see
that's why God says where did you come
from he says oh from walking up and down
on the earth meaning my kingdom the
devil claims this Earth as his so the
fact that there is this meeting taking
place uh we would understand that the
other Representatives the other worlds
they were aware of this Rebellion you
read in uh Revelation 12 talks about war
in heaven Michael and his angels 40
against the dragon and his angels and
the dragon lost and he was cast out of
Heaven probably the devil and the angels
that joined his Rebellion kind of wed
through space you might say looking for
a place that they could claim as a
capital they probably tempted or tried
to tempt these other worlds but they
weren successful right around that time
God then starts creating again and he
creates Earth and the devil says Ah
here's my chance uh man and woman
created in the image of God let me see
if I can deceive them and of course he
comes and you know what happened in the
Garden of Eden so yes the other um
created beings the Angels the unfallen
world they're aware of this Rebellion
that took place yeah and I'm going to
add one more verse there that goes right
along with what you're saying in
Revelation
12:2 it seems in the context is is
Jesus's crucifixion and the devil being
cast out in some secondary sense right
uh it says therefore Rejoice oh heavens
and you who dwell in them okay so
there's this party in heaven and those
who dwell there in probably not just
heaven heaven but like the heavens
surrounding worlds perhaps could be
included and then it says woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and the Sea for
the devil has come down to you having
great wrath because he knows that he has
a short time so there it seems right
that the devil after the cross in some
significant way is sort of Trapped to
the Earth right alluding to before this
point he had some kind of access as we
see in the Book of Job to Heavens
Heavenly intelligences other unfallen
beings perhaps um to yes attempt to
spread his lies but of course we're
thankful
uh that well not thankful that humans
rebelled but we're thankful that we are
the only planet that has rebelled and
that God is working through the plan to
sort of in quarantine here on planet
Earth right waiting for the restoration
of all things all right thank you who do
we have next all right next we have
Janette calling in from Michigan and I I
I pastored in Michigan for almost seven
years so uh a warm place in my heart has
is Michigan so Janette welcome to the
program for the first time what's your
question for us good evening good
evening good evening Pastor um my
question is in Judges chapter 19 um what
happens with the Levites concubine is
really bothersome even when she returns
home in verse 29 but my question is why
do they offer their own family such as
their daughters and concubines to evil
men instead of their visitors lot did
the same but he had angels I could
understand that this was just you know
random visitors it seems but you know he
he offered them his daughter and
concubine for um their horrible things
yeah absolutely well that's you know
that's a good question of course to us
today it would be terrible I mean the
last thing uh a father would want to do
is allow anything bad to happen to his
family you'd think he'd be the first one
to step out there in defense the culture
was a little different back in Bible
times in that if you brought a stranger
into your house it was your
responsibility to take care of him and
they took that very serious uh so in the
case for example of lot and in the case
of the story that you read about about
the Levites concubine uh the owner of
the house you know went out and said to
these wicked men please do not do this
thing now of course they they wanted
they wanted the man in both cases uh it
says they wanted to know them Connally
and and perhaps the thinking would be is
well you know if they send a woman may
maybe they wouldn't be that mean but uh
apparently yeah they were Wicked on both
accounts um it's a terrible story you
wonder why is it even in the Bible Well
the reason it's in the Bible is because
this led to civil war in Israel and The
Tribe of Benjamin was almost wiped out
and it it was terribly painful for the
nation but that that was because of this
wickedness that was done uh here in the
story in chapter 19 so that's why it's
even referenced here in the in the
scriptures because of the the terrible
things that happened so yeah it might be
a little different for us today we might
struggle to try and understand it but it
was it was the most important thing back
in Bible times that you were to take
care of the visitor that came under your
roof at at any cost and that's probably
what helped motivate those decisions
well they're not good decisions you know
the Bible gives us both good and bad and
uh that was a bad thing that they did
yeah and then just one more principle to
keep in mind when you're reading
difficult stories in particular in the
Book of Judges there's actually two
verses that sort of set the the whole
theme of The Book of Judges and it's
judges CH
17:6 and judges CH 21 verse 25 which is
the very last verse of the whole Book of
Judges and it says this in those days
there was no king in Israel and everyone
did what was right in his own eyes
showing basically that hey there's a lot
of messed up stuff happening here
because instead of as a caller earlier
referred to proverbs 3:
5 and 6 instead of trusting in God to
direct your path they were trusting in
their own knowledge right and so these
are the consequences this is the kind of
gross messed up stuff that we see when
people do things in their own eyes and
God is is working with sinful humans
even Israelites that claim to serve him
uh at that time and even today can go
astray in different ways when they lose
sight of of God's principles and his
Direction a good point that's a very
good point and of course if you reject
the law of God you reject the counsil of
God you're probably going to get your
counsel from the Pagan Nations around
you and this was common in the Nations
around Israel so they just adopted these
Pagan Traditions you have that strong
culture and then bringing in some of
those surrounding Nations very good all
right well thank you okay our next
caller is calling in uh from D Creek
Oregon uh we have Chris here joining the
program with us um hello there Chris
what is your question for us this
evening hi there thank you for taking my
call was Satan tricked into crucifying
Jesus and this this is a claim that's
emerged from the the popular movement
with the Gen Genesis 6 confusion yeah
and so I'm just curious I think they
based it off the the healing of the
demoniacs and the the demons seem kind
of Clueless to Jesus's purpose his his
ministry thank you well I I you know we
don't know the mind of Satan but
obviously we understand that he is is so
bent on evil that he can't even control
himself I mean he can read the Bible he
knows Bible prophecy better than we have
and yet he still continues down the path
of wickedness he knows what his final
end is going to be but it's as if he's
he's pass the point of rational thinking
um he hated Jesus of course he first
tried to tempt Jesus into worshiping him
and when that failed he did everything
he can to try and hinder the work of
Christ he inspired you know Judas the
scariot he inspired the religious
leaders and the Romans to eventually
crucify Jesus but it almost seems that
after Christ submitted to that it's as
if the devil wanted Jesus to come down
off the cross because I think he
realized that if Christ went through
with the sacrifice you know Salvation
finally he would be overthrown so it
almost seems that he wanted Jesus to
exercise his divine power and come down
off the cross that was a real temptation
to Christ that's why Jesus said if it's
possible let this cup pass from mean not
my will but thy will be done so yeah was
the devil tricked into crucifying Jesus
no I don't think so I I don't think he
could really help himself he was so evil
but when Christ actually submitted then
the devil realized man I I wanted to
exercise his power and come down off the
cross but of course Jesus didn't he
remained there and that's why we have
hope of eternal life we have salvation
amen because of Christ's willingness to
suffer amen all right thank you Chris
all right our next caller is Samuel
calling in from Washington this is a
first time caller and uh Samuel it seems
that you're quite young and you have a
an interesting question for us this
evening hi Samuel how old are you I am
11 years old and my question is are
dinosaurs going to be in heaven oh great
question all right well thank you for
calling Sammy we're glad you're
listening will dinosaurs be in heaven
well I think there's going to be animals
in heaven that you can't even begin to
imagine you know there are dinosaurs I
matter of fact I think there are
dinosaurs even mentioned in the Bible
the Bible speaks about something called
uh the Behemoth and if you look at the
description given in job it talks about
this giant animal that eats Reeds he's
down by the the water he's vegetarian
but he has a thick tail and he's massive
bigger than all the other animals so
yeah it could very well be that in
heaven when you get there you get to get
a dinosaur pet maybe a real big dinosaur
that sleeps in your front yard I don't
know but the Bible says I is not Seen
Nor Ear heard neither has it even
entered into the heart of man the things
that God is preparing for those that
love him so yes it could very well be
that there will be good dinosaurs in
heaven not the bad ones there's going to
be no death you don't have to be afraid
of any animals but yes there will be
some wonderful animals in heaven all
right our next caller is Pam calling in
from Washington uh hello Pam welcome to
the program what's your question for
us hi I just want to know how come when
Jes Jesus was speaking to his disciples
privately and said don't go or listen to
one that comes from a desert or secret
chamber that would be the Antichrist and
it would deceive the very elect they
happen to be his
elect so and then he never said anything
about Paul because at the end of that
chapter it says he's coming back as
lightning strikes in a blinking eye like
blink why didn't he tell him about Paul
okay let me get right in there because
we can run out of time uh so when Jesus
said those things he was was referring
to his disciples but even more it was
prophetic because it's talking about the
second coming of Christ so he's talking
about us in the last days and he says
don't be deceived friends we're going to
have to end for those listening live but
the rest stay by we'll be right
back thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located located in Granite Bay
California all right welcome back for
our final rapid fire uh question time
and these questions are specifically
taken from those who have uh submitted
questions ahead of time through email
and if you would like to submit a
question via email for us to answer at
the end of our program you can submit
them to B questions at amazingfacts.org
so without any further Ado let's get to
our questions more asks I have heard
that we should long for Christ's Second
Coming how can I long for the second
coming when so many people have not yet
been saved all right well that's a good
question uh Jesus says of course one of
the prophets in the scripture say that
the Lord is not slack concerning his
promise talking about the second coming
but he longsuffering towards us not
willing that any should perish why isn't
Jesus come yet well he's want to give as
much time as he possibly can for people
to make that decision to serve him so on
the one hand yes we are sad but on the
other hand you know this world is
getting worse and worse and there's a
lot of suffering that people are
experiencing here on this earth when
Jesus comes there's going to be no more
war no more pain no more sorrow he's
going to make all things new so on the
one hand we want him to come but on the
other hand we saying Lord but what about
this person what about that person God
knows the perfect time and we can just
trust in him knowing that he's going to
do everything he can to try and save
people all right our next question by
chairman uh he asks in relation to
Leviticus uh where there's laws
discussing clean and unclean Meats
basically did these laws also apply to
pets okay uh you know some of the
animals that we have running around our
house today would be considered unclean
for example dogs and cats you can't eat
dogs and cats um is it okay to have pets
did the Israelites have pets well we
know they had donkeys and donkeys are
unclean and they use donkeys uh you can
use unclean animals you can have unclean
pets just just don't eat them that's
what the Bible was referring to all
right our next question Candice asks do
you have to be perfect to get to heaven
um in a previous episode Pastor Doug
referred to being perfect in order to go
to heaven what what what is he talking
about is it perfect before Jesus comes
or after or okay when we receive Jesus
as our personal Savior and we confess
our sins the Bible says he's faithful
and just to forgive us and to cleanse us
from all unrighteousness we are standing
before God just as if we have never
sinned and as long as we are trusting in
Jesus allowing the Holy Spirit work
within us we can trust that at that time
we will be found completely clothed in
his righteousness and yes we will be
perfect but as long as we keep allowing
the Holy Spirit to dwell within us we
keep trusting he will finish the good
work that he has started well friends
thank you so much for joining us for
Bible answers live hopefully we answered
your question join us again next week
for a new
[Music]
episode this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at 800
83567 47 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]